today's question comes from dominic in
new jersey
and he asks how much or a rule of thumb
should be my target for retirement
my current goal is to achieve around 3
million before the age of 62 to 67
depending upon my retirement medical
benefits
i currently max out my 401k and have a
roth ira
but still feel like it won't be enough
is there an ideal amount
well here's the reality dominic is we've
developed a free tool that is going to
help you with this
it's called the riq the retire inspire
quotient a free tool once again at my
website chrishogan360.com
that will help you understand your
ballpark number but it'll take it a step
further my friend
and show you how much you need to be
investing to get there now you're maxing
out 401k so you're putting
19.5 away in it and if you're over 50
you've got an extra 6000
you could do on a catch-up provision as
well as your iras you don't tell me your
age but i'm going to tell you this
if your goal is to have around 3 million
and you're following the baby steps
you're going to have more than enough
right because it's going to depend on
your lifestyle
how much you want to travel how many
mission trips do you want to do
and how much giving so the good thing is
is you want to take control
and you want to be the guide of that and
what you're spending and how you're
living
yeah that the you need to know your
retirement iq your
iq that's a good thing and some good
rough and dirty numbers are this
okay if you do what we teach you say 15
of your household income now we don't
know your age and we don't know
um your income but the average household
income in america is just under
60 000 59 and some change
okay and so if you save 15 of that from
age
30 to age 70 you would have
about eight million dollars in a good
mutual fund
if i'm half wrong
you still got double what you're
projecting
and the three million mark here's a good
number okay let's say let's just make up
numbers let's say you made ten percent
on your money at three million dollars
what is that
that's three hundred thousand a year if
you made ten percent you could pull
three hundred thousand a year off and
not touch the three million just the
golden eggs but don't touch the goose
if you pulled off eight percent that'd
be 240
000. so as long as you think you can
live on that then 3 million will be
enough
the trick is to try to have a nest egg
that you can live off of the
money that it creates the way you're
willing to invest it without touching
the egg
that's right i keep mixing the metaphor
up here but
don't crack and scramble the nest egg or
don't shoot the goose that's laying the
golden eggs there's another way of
saying it
the principal amount your base amount is
your goose
and you know you leave that as an
inheritance if you want to burn through
it you can burn through it it's your
money do whatever you want
but you can you can create a perpetual
motion machine
that will sit there and spit off golden
eggs as long as you don't shoot the
goose that's right and here's the
reality
you get yourself out of debt you don't
have the requirement for as much
so that allows you to be more in control
of your lifestyle and what it is you're
doing
you can always find something to do with
it oh yeah give it
i mean and there's other you know
there's another place to travel you
haven't been with the car to buy you and
bought and there's other stuff you can
do
there's ways you can enjoy it with
outrageous generosity and
um i've never met someone that goes i
have too much
no me neither i have met people who are
spiritually inept and they never get to
enough
because they don't they can't reach
contentment
as an independent discussion apart from
the amount
right but in terms of the math part i've
never met somebody went
yeah i just i screwed that up i got
double what i should have had
i never hear that no i've never either
so if your three is six
or your six is 12 million then that's
okay that's all right i never dreamed i
would end up where i am today
when i was broke and starting to invest
i just wanted to reach enough that i
could live off the income of it
and once i reached that then i just kept
going
uh but not because i'm greedy or piling
up money or i'm building bigger barns or
i'm
you know it's i can increase my
generosity and i can increase the
fact that i change my family tree and
you know if if i've got my way if i
teach my kids and my grandkids
and i leave them money this could be the
dumbest ramsay
in the stretch of family tree i could
have changed the whole stinking thing
yeah you really good get rid of the
stupidity and the brokenness all in one
generation
just leave it all with this one with the
old man that did it he's the one that
changed it you know
and that's that's cool that's a cool
goal to have
so i think he's in a great shape there i
do too now once again
if you're out there and you're thinking
okay how much do i need well again the
riq is the retirement tire inspired
quotient
free tool that allows you to plug in
numbers plug in
and how much you want to live on and how
much and how long
and it's a tool so you can change the
rates of return and
withdrawal rates the goal is is to make
people more
aware of why you're saving your 401k
becomes your paycheck later
right so we've got to put money in to be
able to grow to outpace inflation
so you have a paycheck later and that's
what dave was just talking about so
check it out chrishogan360.com